foreign
it's not black white it's male female
I think that's the issue that we're
running into no it is black and white
it's very black and white
you understand like we're in a trap
it is a trap let me say this it didn't
start out that way you made me feel that
way every single conversation today has
been productive we found more in common
than less every single one yeah with the
exception of this this is the only one
where I was told I couldn't have an
opinion because of white fragility and I
just have an opinion I thought this
conversation would have been completely
different
you'll be able to see the behavior that
you
exhibited here you not myself and you
can watch it and you can rewind it
that's what you think of black women
the reason that a lot of white people
don't have these kinds of conversations
like this is because they're afraid of
being accused of being no they're afraid
of being accused of being racist yeah
well see that's that isn't a tax you
just say white fragility we're on I
think we're on the same page you're just
defining it as a difference why agility
means when white people are afraid to
confront the fact that they might have
racism or might have racist thoughts
that's what agility so what if they
don't they don't literally almost
everybody in America does
foreign
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder with
crowder.com mug club for 89 annually
join the fight at lottery.com mug club
today
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm just I'm just laughing because
sometimes you guys don't get to see what
happens right before we go to Air and uh
tool man was losing his mind at the uh
the Oprah understudy teaser that you
just saw there that conversation was
infuriating it's like an hour late shut
the f up put this headphones
he's like oh what racist thoughts you
know what I'm thinking now shut down
what am I thinking yeah
TV screen
you're thinking about Roots
no I'm just saying that's what they
wanted so that will go up tomorrow and
just to be clear this black and white
and the gray issues they're usually like
very we're doing one in a barber shop
here going forward these late tool man
you you were there they we turned back
on all of our camera equipment we were
ready to go home you making a movie
every movie should have me in it
remember that was her exact quote Yeah
Yeah I said okay and then we ran the
cameras exactly as we had conversations
with everyone else and it devolved very
quickly and it went on for an hour but
spoiler alert we end up finding some I
still reeled them back and we found some
common ground there at the end of that
conversation good wrap-up we made a
special accommodation yes we did
we were gone we haven't had your theme
song yet okay I can chime in that's all
right by the way hit the hit the like
button because it helps the algorithm on
YouTube and also hit like if if you feel
tool man's pain and show some solidarity
with him
and we'll be talking about this today
look one thing I want to be clear about
there's a reason that we have Alex Jones
here at mug Club you know you have him
on Fridays Nick depaolo people like Jim
Brewer people like Brian count obviously
Yours Truly here these are people who um
have risked something but I also
understand and hopefully and you guys
can comment below you understand that I
don't agree with all of these people on
all issues Alex and I have had
disagreements on air but I'm not going
to be I I feel compelled and I think
there are a lot of people out there you
feel compelled to defend these folks
when there's a pile on two things can be
true maybe you don't even like Alex
Jones personally but you have to
acknowledge the guy has the right to
speak and he's been right about a lot
maybe you don't like the proud boys
though what is it that you think you
don't like about the proud boys let's
assume that you don't all right
you can still hold that position and
understand that it is a travesty of
justice for someone to be getting 22
years who wasn't there on January 6th
committed no violence and encouraged no
violence by the prosecutor's own
admission so we're going to give you the
ins and outs there today because guess
what you are next if they can do this 22
years everything else and by the way at
the same time as not Prosecuting violent
felons from the Riots of black lives
matter you do not live in a free country
if you have laws only if the laws are
applied equally we also have an
exclusive mug Club undercover there's a
Washington school that has been
promoting black lives matter flags and
uh progress Flags the progress pride and
a parent sent us an email and there's
actually already been some developments
since then so we're talking about all
that and more Gerald a how are you sir
I'm doing well I love it when Tim loses
his stuff right before
typically it's like he's waiting on a
clip or something and uh and that's what
it was but it was this I love it tool
man just you know what's great about
tool man is he has no desire to like be
famous or to be in the line he just he's
a utility player but he loses his mind
about sex he does he's incredibly he's
like I don't care about being famous I
just want to end lives
like oh man don't piss toolman off he's
just like a little not literally he's
like a well yeah and he's so strong he's
just like a walking sinew of hate
all right and then when you hear this
that means in third chair you know him
you love him I came from his loins uh
pops Crowder how are you sir all the
thumbs down buttons were just clicked no
no there are no thumbs down anymore you
know I hate that I can't chime in on Tim
losing it free uh you know
pre-announcement no I can't chime in
until you actually you already did I
know but I was I was admonished for it
you saw the sign and you bucked it
anyway you took a ticket on that right
and uh that also by the way he just
found out this morning that his beloved
ice coffee he gets in the morning is 400
milligrams of caffeine wow he sometimes
gets a large iced coffee from Duncan 400
milligrams of caffeine 2 000 calories as
well no there's no calories not the iced
coffee it's delicious and they're in
neutral so I'm a fan I don't I don't get
the gummy bears sprinkles and caramel
like most folks yeah well that's here's
why that's bad for your brain and that
can also lend itself in here you're
getting up there to alzheimer's dementia
which brings us to his fellow uh fellow
graduating class members uh
from extreme weather events to uh
walking I should provide some context
here before we get to this weekend
button uh you may not know this he
wasn't supposed to walk out on this war
hero no that's why it's so odd and of
course here he is lying about the
economy weather events it's this week in
Biden if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump and you
ain't black I also convened my entire
cabinet as part of a whole of government
response
and that response is to increase the
number and intensity of the extreme
weather events and beware we're going to
be use all the resources available to
the government to do it
[Applause]
ladies and Gentlemen please join me for
the benediction
all right if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for me or Trump and
you ain't black
thank God the former vice president
wasn't in White Christmas
[Laughter]
but to lump me in with him as possible
classmates he could be my father I know
and he would have been Furious because
you're part of you know the uh the
integration uh with school for the first
time there in Detroit and he didn't want
his children going to a racial jungle
also uh big fan of the n-word yeah Vice
President Joe Biden but I wouldn't have
graduated last in my class though that
would have been
laughs
a little buffer there Biden buffer he
looks sharp pop scratter but when we did
we still have the submissions for win a
date with uh Steven Crowder half of them
were for my dad
yeah for my dad yeah let your mom know
don't wait so we're going to by the way
get into uh some claims and truths uh
from former Vice President Biden that
he's making about the economy right now
he's starting his presidential campaign
we've already covered it in the past but
the numbers actually have gotten worse
since we last covered it uh but before
we get to that you know sometimes we get
exclusives like we have my club
undercover later on uh and Mitch
McConnell actually by the way this is
right here on CNN just to give you a
heads up Lindsey Graham just said he was
concerned about Mitch McConnell which is
just again it's like yeah the these 75
year old is concerned about the 95 year
old
it's like the house spring chicken it's
the chambers cocoon
someone get Gutenberg so as bad as that
did look right what you just saw there
um it actually does get worse McConnell
is concerned uh sorry Graham is
concerned about McConnell but former
Vice President Joe Biden did say that he
had called McConnell and we have the
exclusive uh leaked audio
hello
come on no
no you are calling
calling me chef what am I ordering
here you talk to him yeah no you are
calling Mitch too that's right it's his
birthday
Happy Birthday
Mr President
I talked to him
Miss
Michelle Mr
said unbelievable
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's key yeah to make sure you wipe
after every time yes yeah good job no no
it has been wiped
for him four yes yes no somebody has I'm
going through potty training I know what
that's all about yeah man there's like
better interactions with the
two-year-olds yes yeah they're more
communicative than that was actually the
inspiration for the whisper right if you
see me then you know my son will go okay
[Laughter]
okay
it's similar if you have two-year-olds
come on guys sometimes sometimes you
just need it let's put let's let's zoom
out here
you believe this man is leader of the
fruit you believe this is the most
popular president of all do you believe
this man received more votes than any
other president in history and you
believe that this man is fit to serve
this man is fit to be in the Oval Office
what let me put this in context what
other job would you entrust to former
Vice President Biden if you run a
company out there I was thinking about
this this morning there's not one I was
going edit Bay no
research absolutely not
getting coffees it's still a liability
there's no way they'll spill it on
himself burn his liver spotted hands
yeah that's true it would just melt down
that paper tissue paper and like like
you look at the Ark of the Covenant
it's just anything nobody's fit to be
present come on guys let's have some do
you know how we know the game is rigged
they want you to believe that former
vice president but I never respect the
office is leader of the Free World and
he doesn't he's not even he's he's not
even convincing his heart isn't even in
the lies so let's get into this here on
Labor Day he went out again he's
preparing his campaign touting his job
creation now it's a lie but serious
watch him like I said
in my first two years I've created
nearly 13.5 million jobs more jobs in
two years than any president has created
in a four-year term okay all right okay
let's go through the claims this is his
claim right that he just made that okay
created 13.5 million jobs while I'm
learning the president okay here's the
truth all right
and we make all the references publicly
available the vast majority of those
jobs are returning jobs that were lost
due to covet right we saw record job
growth but most importantly and we'll
Circle back to this we saw record wage
growth for all Americans black white
middle class upper middle class wealthy
all of them and I get it some people say
yeah but the wealthy got even well
through yep but so did you covetousness
is a is a sin sweetheart
so the vast majority returned covet
right let's be let's be honest about
what this is here was internationally
orchestrated coven not the virus I'm not
saying the virus doesn't exist but it
was designed to shut down the economy
and force people to vote from home so
9.37 million jobs were lost to covid in
2020 alone so let's do that math right
he says 13.5 9.37 in just 2020. a
million jobs were lost so there's about
four million jobs there and this wasn't
like a Great Depression kind of moment
or a 2008 stock market crash kind of
moment it was literally the government
turning the tap off and then turning it
back on right that's why it's a
different measurement and they can't
tout 13.5 with any kind of seriousness
at all no so this brings us to another
claim here that he's trying to make that
well awesome actually employer employers
by the way have been adding record jobs
since then 180 187 000 jobs in August
the economy is doing great okay here's
the truth about that the job report was
really bad I'll get to the 4 million
jobs Credit in a second unemployment
went from 3.5 to 3.8 percent here's what
they're leaving out
1.2 million native born Americans lost
jobs they have lost jobs 688
000 foreign-born workers have gained
jobs really yes when you're talking
about visas you're talking about the
lottery visas wow you're talking about
people so in other words this is the
issue it's not about I don't think
there's a more clear statistic it's not
about immigration it's not about dirt or
brown people no that's not what it is
for some people for some for some people
for some for some people it's a former
Vice President Biden and probably you
know his family reunion I bet you you
probably hear that question there's
brown people
yeah
1.2 million American jobs lost 688 000
imported jobs this is how you know
they're not looking now here's some you
certainly can import those votes pay 688
000 hold on a second what was the margin
of error in those key States Arizona was
ten thousand yeah a lot of these states
were within 30 688
000 foreign-born workers came now I
don't know how many of them are eligible
eligible to vote I don't know how many
of them got citizenship how many of them
got green cards versus work visas but
the point is they're trying to establish
a voting base
for all time Americans lose jobs and we
import jobs that's a problem that's a
policy problem that everyone should be
on board with solving yeah and by the
way they're not even right on these jobs
reports numbers every single time
they've had a report this year it's been
revised down by as much as almost half
in one month I think in June they were
off by 48 or something yeah they had to
lower it down to 110 000 jobs for the
last just for the last two months so I
can't even believe the numbers that
they're giving me right now it's like I
was 180 something thousand jobs are you
sure about that sorry did I say 187 I
meant 90.
1000 no no jobs
just 90. and uh I want you to comment
below that's the beauty of also having
You Know sample size how is your
financial situation changed how is your
employment situation changed since
former Vice President Biden has been uh
I guess sort of wheeled into office
um
but by the way Chad thinks he would make
a great Walmart greeter oh well that's
because the minimum age is like 95. yeah
that's true it comes with a
complimentary oxygen tank
somebody says you could probably get out
with more than your 900 of uh yeah he's
not chasing yeah I can't imagine him
checking Costco
[Laughter]
what do I do yeah what's that it's a
robot vacuum holy hell
I'm frightened it learns
so many numbers
so
here's name that reference though Gerald
you're a Seinfeld fan yeah no so I don't
know thank you look and this is the most
important claim that you need to be
ready to debunk because you'll probably
hear this at Thanksgiving when you go
into election season so here's the claim
that they're making and it is verifiably
uh false misleading you could say untrue
and again we'll make the references
always publicly available he has tried
to say that he's created millions of new
jobs outside of now he's trying to say
get rid of the rebound from the pandemic
which by the way your party pushed oh
and also you said you would never take
the vaccine because of operation warp
speed when it was Donald Trump's vaccine
until you took credit but I digress
um
he's trying to say that four million new
jobs outside of the pandemic rebound
have been created so that's not true but
you'll hear this a lot here's a clip of
him starting that tour we've recovered
all the jobs lost during the pandemic
we've added Millions more okay so here's
the truth and context matters here
abortion depending on which numbers most
of them part-time jobs or very low
paying jobs yeah so since February of
2021 3.6 million part-time jobs have
been created okay 37 of Americans have
more than one full-time job right now 56
percent are considering a second job
there are more right now Americans
working multiple jobs uh than in recent
history I don't know if we have the
numbers going back all the way to the
1970s but I do know that in recent
decades there are more Americans working
part-time jobs working two jobs and more
Americans than ever working three jobs
working three shifts just to be clear
and pretty important with this by the
way weekly earnings down 3.6 percent
since Biden took off and that doesn't
sound like a whole lot but combine that
with the inflation rate so you're you're
earning less money and it's worth less
anyway yes so that probably comes out to
I don't know I'm not not a math guy but
that these are fake jobs yes Americans
have significantly less money today than
they did in the past when adjusted for
inflation or when not adjusted for
inflation and you add into that 30-year
fixed mortgage rates right they've
soared since former Vice President Biden
has been uh you know in office
7.18 is the current rate January of 2021
was 2.7
2.77 I think yeah so I haven't done the
math but I think that means that you're
in those golden handcuffs if you were to
get into a new house let's say you sell
your house and it's worth half a million
and you have to get a new mortgage you
probably have to get a house at around
000 something like that over the course
of its lifetime I mean the amount that
you are going to be paying in interest
so these jobs aren't new just to be
clear they're part-time jobs there are
jobs full-time jobs that have been lost
forever more Americans millions of
Americans have lost their full-time jobs
but we've imported good news is over 600
000 foreign jobs and your your money is
basically worthless right now uh
contextually
compared to what you would have had
pre-pandemic right but he added so many
jobs yeah that's what he's going to go
out and say and nobody's going to
challenge him on this none of the media
are going to point out the fact that all
of those things that we just said are
true and if look if his number of added
jobs is 4 million and it's 3.6 million
part-time jobs yeah I get it that people
need to get a part-time job but not when
it's 30 percent of the population
considering a second job that already
work full-time right and 50 some odd
percent considering a third job are you
serious right that's the trust in
government has gone away you know it's
not because they lie about this stuff
and they tell you that yeah they tell
you it's rain while they're peeing on
your forehead yeah they aren't objective
reports anymore they're all opinions and
spin so well you know they say there are
lies damn lies and statistics now here's
the thing statistics matter facts matter
but
tell me if you noticed this trend
um I do think that context often matters
more than content when we talk about
content with the show I do think that
context with numbers particularly when
you're dealing with the economy they do
matter and you don't have to get
incredibly nerdy you don't have to have
uh you know you don't have to have a PhD
in bit whatever that is when people get
this master's degree in business like
what just go start a business
so you don't have to be a genius but you
do have to go one level deeper do you
notice that the numbers the left always
they always pull and you can see this if
you I highly recommend that you follow
Joe Biden the White House on Instagram
because they put out these numbers that
just require a quick search to see is
fake and this always brings up the
question hold on a second do they not
have Google or Bing or that bent back
paper clip from the you know Word
document or are they lying
so they always take the largest number
with zero context for example Barack
Obama went out and said wage Gap women
make 77 cents in the dollar now the only
way you can make that argument is if you
just compare the very broad men's
salaries to women's salaries you're not
taking into account degree experience
number of hours worked it's just average
male pay across all spheres of work and
women for example another step they say
guns are the number one killers of
children the only thing that you need to
look look up to see that that's false is
hold on a second what are the
demographics oh wait a second you take
away the 15 to 19 year olds enter gang
violence in urban areas it's not even
close
so the only way they can make the
argument oh wage Gap is if you just go
okay compare salary with no context the
only way they can make the argument it's
number one killer of children well if
you consider 15 to 19 year olds children
right otherwise it's drowning otherwise
it's automobile accidents otherwise it's
toasters for crying out loud it's the
same thing here with the jobs when they
say oh a job's created okay they have to
use the broadest statistics possible
they don't include part-time work they
don't include the average salary the
average wages they don't include the
hours worked so it's ah wage Gap hold on
one step deeper shows you're
bullshitting ah guns number one killer
of children hold on one step deeper
shows you're bullshitting oh more jobs
created hold on one step deeper shows
that you are bullshitting and it's
always the case it's supposed to be the
party of the intellectuals don't let
them Gaslight you because you wear a
Maga hat as though they're smarter than
you they're just liars
when it feels like they get away with it
because it's just you know you know that
term headline news that network is that
still a thing h m right HLN well I don't
know if it's Ln but you know there was
HLN for headline
headline yeah
I don't know doctor Network guy Dr
Grayson Nancy Drew it feels like the
only thing that they're doing is saying
stuff to get a headline and nobody does
any any other research after that it's
like I want the headline to be that the
economy is doing well and that people
are doing better than they were before
but I pray to God they don't do any
research and actually by the way we've
got a lot of chats I don't know if we
can bring them up like we've got a lot
of chats of people saying no they can't
they're making you know living paycheck
to paycheck by the way thank you for
supporting Mud Club if you're in that
position thank you very much for
spending your hard-earned dollar which
obviously we do not take that club here
yeah exactly thank you very much for
that people people have a real
Experience day to day that does not
match what politicians are saying yeah
and the right and left do this the right
does it in other ways the left doesn't
you should be called out either way yeah
these numbers are terrible the economy
is not doing well that's why there's no
way that this guy wins the election
unless there's unless unless nefarious
activity unless was it stolen that
sounds like a YouTube but you're allowed
to question election results right now I
mean it's well you're you're there's no
way he wins this election unless it's
stolen just to be clear you know what
just call me Amy Klobuchar call me uh uh
call me Hillary Clinton call me Jimmy
Carter who all said that the only way
Donald Trump could win is if he stole it
and then when he did win it they said
that he stole it the only way that this
guy wins because of the disconnect
because you right now at home with the
clicker on your couch I don't know I
don't know how you're watching this you
should be watching it on your phone the
point is you know what it is that you
are living and you know and even the
average American who isn't politically
involved knows that something doesn't
smell right that's how you turn people
against you historically it's pretty
much always happened
pretty much always happened when the
leadership when the elites become so out
of touch that they don't even seem to be
representing the people who have elected
them that's when they lose power you're
seeing that right now with Trudeau yeah
and you are seeing the disconnect with
this former vice president and the media
is still trying to prop him up still
trying to drag him across that Finish
Line you know weekend at it's not going
to work the only way this guy wins is if
it's stolen you step in yourself Weekend
At Bernies absolutely weak into Bernie's
yeah I don't think that's particularly
original that's why I felt ashamed
of Bernie's too I think you're gonna get
to that that net number of people under
Trump versus people under Biden and
their net how far are they ahead yeah
well the average salary increase I don't
have it uh here in the map the average
salary increase under Donald Trump the
first three years was over five thousand
dollars yeah I think it was eighteen
hundred dollars over eight years of
Obama and then if you adjust for and
this is all adjusted for inflation with
Biden it went down yeah the numbers
Gap is like eight thousand dollars
that's real yeah it's huge it's a huge
gap and then you can't buy a house now
right you have to rent you're you're
kind of a perm permanent renters class
people look at that percent like oh two
to seven percent nothing that's like you
that is the going from I can afford to
make this house payment and have some
money left over to do some savings too
there's no way in hell I can afford to
have a house well the good news is if
you rent you know who the biggest
purchaser of good companies that we know
and trust we have single family housing
units yeah Vanguard BlackRock who by the
way Elizabeth Warren deemed too big to
fail oh so they get Perpetual bailouts
so you don't buy a house you give them
your money and then when their business
model doesn't work Elizabeth Warren
being the for the people socialist that
she is has determined that Vanguard and
BlackRock are too big to fail and it's
never ending hey by the way have you
gotten your residual checks for the
vaccine yet don't know if you remember
this you pay for that
your profits and had no liability
where's uh former Vice President Biden
where's Bernie Sanders maybe he's spoken
out of where's the Democratic party
speaking on behalf of you the working
you paid for this vaccine you subsidized
it well that's fine if you get your
money back
hey even a CD right now is what 2.5
which isn't that good historically you
get nothing you pay for it and then the
profits go to these companies well no
the big Pharma is now good I don't know
if you got yes yesterday on the left big
Pharma is fantastic they've never done
anything wrong drugs have never hurt
people and and profits are fine well
Biden's trying to step in now and say
look I'm discounting drugs for seniors
you know you know that was glad handing
hey hey we gave you many many billions
how about you discount a few at election
time for us and I'll look at that give
us something by the way and they're
already existing drugs for decades so
it's free for them to do it they get a
little discount and Biden you know wears
it like you try to take credit for
Donald Trump's you know slashing of
insulin prices but oh I know he was like
insulin should only be what 30 bucks a
month or something like that for for
people and I was like that's because
I've heard this before and by the way
itself if she drinks that like it's Mr
Freeze
that's when no children it's just
because it's pancreas doesn't work I
don't think it's diabetes nothing works
everything's going now
he looks like he's just made a glass
like he could if he bumped the podium
he's gonna dislocate
oh well
all right here's this is an exclusive
that we yet now thank you again your
support with mug Club it supports our
undercover um journalism unit so this is
a school district and there have been
some developments actually just Gerald
just done this today let me let me make
sure you know the name and you know the
people involved and then you can send
your emails to make your voices heard so
it's Ridgefield School
I guess original is a school district
yeah School District the school district
is Ridgefield Ridgefield Bing School
District in Washington uh has been
Washington State yes Washington
all right
okay the Ridgefield School District you
want me to you want me to be you want to
turn me into something the Richfield
School District in Washington state
Gerald
what are the original virals I love it
oh it's a classic this is basically a
suburb of Portland that happens to be
across the river in Washington exactly
okay just to be clear are we good may I
do the introduction please
so this was brought to our attention by
a concerned parent they are
indoctrinating children right now you
saw that with the Gadsden flag right you
saw the reaction that you guys well this
is the flip side of that coin we're
going to share the story of this
concerned parent and the insane
interactions that she had with the
school uh and as it turns out the
problem is actually way deeper than even
she knew this is my club undercover our
eyes and ears
thank you
all right so this comes in from uh and
by the way you can always send your tips
is it lwc yeah you have the email yeah
let me see tips protonmail.com and we
will protect your anonymity with our
life so this parent let's call her Mrs Z
from Ridgefield Washington not like Z
like in the the gender I know it's just
come on let's not let them steal letters
from us
too late you're interrupting his float
this person reached out to us with this
email uh regarding the events from uh
late 2022 it said uh there's a giant
black lives matter flag and pride flag
in the Math teachers room which faces
the hallway that all kids walk through
before trying before trying the formal
complaint written route
I had a meeting with the superintendent
as soon as I knew about the flag and
also a school board member but they
pretty much said that they were
powerless because of the teachers unions
so then this person Mrs Z issued a
formal complaint and this is what you
all of you out there as parents should
do uh issue this formal complaint with
the school
citing racial discrimination which I
like that's a power move so um she said
that uh uh Stephanie horn was engaging
in anti-white people propaganda and has
created a contentious adversarial space
on school grounds this promotes violence
Division and stating that just lives
black lives matter is discrimination
based on color and that is against state
and federal regulations now the
Ridgefield School District
superintendent Nathan McCann the name
being McCann last name first name Nathan
I say this because these people right
there's a huge difference these these
people uh they're supposed to serve you
hey Public School these are the true
heroes right well let's show you just
how heroic they are well denied uh
taking action declined to take action
stating I have determined that it was
appropriate and not racially
discriminatory for the district not to
direct Mrs horn to remove the black
lives matter in progress Pride flags
from the windows of her classroom as you
know due to your employment for the
redacted government workers including
School teachers do not lose all their
first amendment rights by the nature of
their public employment so think of when
people talk about the different the
power differential right in
relationships
uh men in the workplace white people in
the workplace is there any greater power
differential than teacher and student so
teachers First Amendment protected your
taxpayer dollars by the way uh students
no
parents no yeah just to be clear that's
an issue these children have to sit at
wrapped attention they have no choice
and these are big flags by the way when
we show that image I didn't realize they
took up the entire window and there's
two of them side by side yeah let's
indicate with the Gaston flag and see
what happens
he sent home so and this is the thing
they're saying no no we're allowed to
have the the progress Flags the LGBT can
you bring it up again that overlay of
the flag so people can see the size of
this see how big those are yeah these
aren't two little flags hanging up in
the corner by the way one of the
policies of the district is that you're
not supposed to uh bully anybody or you
know there's some
[Music]
lives matter you should be able to say
that I think we should be able to put
that right next to it yep doesn't that
make sense I guarantee the school
district would probably step in at that
point and say well hold on you're
telling black people that their lives
don't matter when you say all I've met
well why yeah yeah that that's not what
you're saying with the black lives
matter flag there so it's just
happenstance that there are no all lives
matter flags at this school
to the best of our knowledge we've
checked how about us just happen since
you mean there oh wait a second that's
right it's the calling process before
you hire these teachers if you don't
share these points of view you don't get
hired you're not allowed in a club that
is a teacher's Union because they want
to ensure that this kind of propaganda
reaches your children day in and day out
eight hours a day and as a parent you
have no say in the matter oh and by the
way you want to you want to use Charter
Schools you want school choice no no
we're actually going to push for
legislation actively that removes that
choice it is a racket it is it is a
criminal Enterprise what they do with
Public Schools right now this is not
about educating children this is about
creating an army of foot soldiers it's
the Foot Clan yeah
and we're very effective yes the Foot
Clinic but by the way Clan before you
say no we're not talking about hoods
we're talking about masks Ninja Turtles
not Clan doesn't always mean you know
burning crosses or it's not real yeah
it's not real I get that Roots was
pre-clan Era but you understand the
point
now here's the thing too by the way
people have free speech here in this
office not everyone agrees with me on
everything not everyone agrees with you
we had a very similar situation we had
someone black lives matter flags at
their desk progress at their desk yeah
uh and we didn't fight we um we just we
just moved their desk
[Music]
hello
is anyone there
the last few nights you set the alarm
and I couldn't get out
I was stuck here eating dog food
oh hello again around even foaming up
[Music]
by the way you guys may want to move his
desk outside yeah because he seems to be
acting erratic I like him where he is
locked up safe unable to leave we still
have a Hannibal Lecter mask from that
and we do let's just yeah got it so
again none of this has just happen
stance the superintendent explicitly
endorses black lives matter oh so this
is a quote from the superintendent the
fact that uh display of by the way the
typos are just crazy the fact that a
display of a black lives matter sign is
not inherently racist or likely to cause
violence within the school environment
is demonstrated by the endorsement of
the black lives matter at school
campaign by both ospi and large
Washington schools
the fact that that flag is not likely to
cause anything to happen at the school
of violence or anything is because we
it's because the school district says so
that's what he points to that is his
empirical evidence yes well that's like
CNN saying these protests are peaceful
because see the lower Chiron says that
ignore the flames it's peaceful
I know it's just it's a depth of field
effect I know it looks like it looks
like Flames are coming out of the back
of my head uh oh they are coming out of
the back of my head but still it's
mostly peaceful you are the
superintendent of a school district and
you say oh because everybody else is
doing this is a justification he's an
educator so you should correct that memo
Lord like a kid's term paper with a red
pen you're like it's unbelievable can
you cite yourself literally that are not
yours you can't cite yourself that's a
source yes it's not how this works I've
tried you you can set yourself if no one
actually has the ability to fire you oh
that's fair so he says uh ospi has
repeatedly tweeted about the black lives
matter at school week described biospi
as involving intentional conversation
centered on racial Justice and Civic
engagement oh okay so you just say
racial Justice Civic invade engagement
and apparently your school district
tweeted some so I feel comfortable
with my children uh next to a male
teacher with blue hair and giant fake
purple
[Music]
no violence is soda associated with the
black lives matter movement as you maybe
have suggested uh Counterpoint have you
seen my tweets
it's lost control of downtown
[Applause]
destroyed then took over their vehicles
man
they're burning a man
widespread into the early morning
oh boy I would have kept driving
there was looting underway nearby if you
landed here from another planet
[Music]
uh it is not uh it is not generally
speaking unruly
listen to this so in there Chris Nick
what they're going to do is they're
going to create what they call a Phalanx
okay they're going to create an angle of
these shields and what they're going to
then have to make a decision to do is to
either hold which is they expect these
windows to be broken and people to
advance or run away remember what we
used to say that hey be careful because
kids will uh they'll they'll mimic what
they see yeah that's always it you know
monkey see monkey do what do you think
happens when you put a flag up and the
kids can run a cursory Google search I
know Google's going to try and also
propagandism as well but but you've now
said that that's acceptable you've now
said well that's not really a threat
this is this is Civic engagement
but what part of any of this has to do
with edu teaching them their
multiplication tables yeah their ABCs or
grammar right this is a high school this
is this I believe this is a high school
but by the way I don't correct me if I'm
wrong uh chop Chas where was that yeah
the good news is these kids they can tag
public property in cursive ah there we
go let's make sure that they can do that
and get the Punctuation correct and by
the way this is another thing from the
superintendent you can comment below
we're we're going to uh of course give
you the ability to uh send in your
complaints make your voices hurt one of
the bigger indicators here is the
superintendent's uh commitment to
whatever we talked about Equity Equity
just to be clear when someone says
Equity they're racist okay you can have
equality not racist which means equal
opportunity or you can have equity which
is insured outcome you cannot have
Equity without affirmative action
without Dei without diversity quotas you
cannot ensure Equity unless you are
picking winners and losers based on race
and identity equality is everyone has an
opportunity you are now based by
something you know content of your
character your actions your actions are
what Define you Equity when you hear it
means this person is a racist by the way
it's also important that you use that
litmus test to differentiate between
people who share your points of view
versus wolves and sheep's clothing if
you see someone who claims who claims
that they are wearing your team jersey
and they use words like Equity no it's
got a car carve that one out so this is
what he says about Equity the Ridgefield
School District is a community of
Learners committed to equity the
principle of equity goes beyond formal
equality where all persons are treated
the same instead Equity Fosters an
inclusive and barrier-free environment
in which everyone will fully benefit now
talk about word salad which this guy
tosses it's
Beyond formal equality where all persons
are treated the same wait hold on a
second why would we never go to why
would we need to go beyond that that
sounds wonderful right
Beyond formal formal equality where
everyone's treated the same you wouldn't
understand you're not a superintendent
instead Equity Fosters meaning it is
different from everyone being treated
the same meaning people are not treated
the same they are treated differently
based on their race sex gender
orientation that is discriminatory this
guy just said the quiet part out loud
and now he's trying to silence a parent
we try to Define equity
as equality he tried to no barriers well
he says yes yeah no barriers but
everyone will fully benefit meaning will
ensure outcomes that's the key detail
right there I love this why wouldn't you
just want everybody to be treated the
same so basically what you're saying is
no barriers what what specifically are
the barriers that you're talking about
because we've already established that
everybody's being treated the same
okay you're so who creates those
barriers because if it's people of color
if it's people who have you know gender
identities or gender persuasion sexual
orientation what you're saying straight
white people aren't you if you have a
wife are you saying straight white if
you have a white boy in the Ridgefield
School District go somewhere else you
need to take your white boy out of
public school at the Ridgefield School
District yeah he just told you they're
not going to be treated the same
that is the starkest power differential
with a teacher and a student there is no
hope for a kid and until a kid's an
adult and paying the teacher to teach
him in form of tuition he really has no
say he's dismissing a parent like he's a
Bangladeshi on tech support
very efficient they also by the way this
district has a history of supporting
radical movements just to be clear and
this always matters when people say oh
the radical left the radical right man
I'm in the middle well hold on we're not
talking about the friends left we're
talking about people on the left tour in
positions of power at every single level
of government the entire DNC all of
public education public sector Union so
March 26 2020 all sources are available
at lotto.com there's a French teacher
wanted to form a book club discussing
white fragility
and wanted reimbursement for buying the
books June 3rd 2020 fifth grade teacher
said in an email that they quote ended
up they debate heading up to Ridgefield
for a black lives matter sign waving
June 9th 2020 the second grade teachers
discussed showing parents and students
black lives matter videos maybe they'll
teach them how to make it we've got a
few for them wait second grade teachers
yeah
seven-year-olds need to have a black
lives matter video for parents and
students why are they so angry mommy
yeah exactly why are they burning things
that's a stereotype of an angry black
person no no no no mommy no I'm not
racist like you are what I mean to say
is
um those people are angry because
they're beating in that man's head
he'll be okay is that our Walgreens
Daddy
used to be black is that where we go and
use it anymore those 996 dollars of free
merchandise won't steal themselves
get to work June 24 2020 the school
librarian asked other staff to send her
for pride month quote a short video or
text and pictures about something or
someone important to the lgbtq plus
rights and visibility boy asking lgbtq
plus to send you pictures you're taking
your life in your hands you should just
give a homework assignment to the other
staff she basically
porn yes then September 1st 2020 a
science teacher told a parent who
objected to a black lives matter
protester back then sorry a poster back
then the teacher was a protester uh that
in science women and people of color
have long been underrepresented I want
students from marginalized populations
to feel safe and supported in my
classroom okay how about this if they
have been underrepresented in science
teach them science
hey Mr Bergeron
Behringer Tom Bergeron's American Tom
Beringer was a substitute yeah caught
the Eraser when I was thrown at him and
then turned like oh you think you're
gonna play
wow you made it he he made his voice
heard on the first day science teacher
they've been underrepresented by the way
if you're a woman if you're a person of
color and you are under qualified for
stem fields in college right now don't
worry you'll get in
wow Equity it's easy that's true stuck
that one
now here's an update the superintendent
at Ridgefield uh School District Nathan
McCann stepped down from the position uh
last month and we it just actually came
out I think that information was just
made public within the last couple of
days maybe the last week something like
that and basically the the they said
that they came to like a mutual parting
of ways his skills and abilities through
no fault of his own or the districts do
you like this like nobody takes any
responsibility for anything that's
happening uh Mutual parting away is this
guy's been there for about a decade
here's a silver lining for you Stephen I
know you like Silver Linings yeah a
little good news the school district has
had several Bond issues for those of you
who don't know that's like please give
us more money because we can do
wonderful things for the lgbtq community
with it they've had them fail twice
recently they aren't getting any more
money from the people who vote on who
gets more money good I know by the way
what percent of that money goes to the
big guy well yes
teachers union goes to the Democrat
Party uh 99 thank you okay 0.9 I think
yeah I was rounding down because I
wanted I didn't want people to call me
on and say no no no no you're
exaggerating just be fair you know what
here hold on a second let's play it
really and let me just call it a cool 98
and it's 98 funded by you hey hold on a
second public teachers how are they your
tax
[Music]
Ridgefield District have any issues
email and I I'm cautiously optimistic
the new Superintendent at chris.griffith
[Music]
ridgefieldsd.org that's chris.griffith
ridgefieldsd.org of course keep it
respectful but if you're a parent in
this District let them know what you
expect to see let them know what is
acceptable if they are in charge of of
teaching your children for eight hours a
day and by the way if you're a teacher
there if you know somebody who is a
teacher there reach out to us I would
love to see okay you have the BLM and
you have the pride flag how about we do
the Christian flag I know you don't see
that flying at a whole lot of places but
we can we can find one I'm sure we can
work that up and in all lives matter
flag how about we balance this thing out
does that sound fair yeah let's see what
your response is the moment that flag
goes up yeah I want the flag that they
hoisted up at Constantinople with the
Crusades
well that's different
God wills it we've done a whole segment
on the Crusades by the way retaliatory
action if you think the Crusades are it
doesn't matter anyway send your emails
to you can just go watch it we did a
whole Deep dive on that lwc tips at
protonmail.com look that Distillery was
shut down this superintendent is going
well we can't take credit for this one
there was a lot happening behind the
scenes to be clear your voices can be
heard you can make a difference on a
local level and then of course you know
mug Club is what we do on a national one
because they can't all be in
charge of the media this has been my
club undercover our eyes and ears
there nothing
all right
by the way I think I think the camera
got adjusted because my desk is it looks
like a it's like a Tim Burton film it's
all off-center yeah you see that I do
yeah I think did someone say hey someone
must have knocked let's make this camera
Dutch angle yeah I want to feel like I'm
watching Doctor I wonder if like I'm
watching uh the cabinet of Dr Caligari
every time
well people party in here and they just
walk by the equipment and knock it
accidentally yeah which by the way let's
fill the liquor bottles with brown Water
yeah oh that's why I didn't get drunk we
have a guy out there who uses a dip just
have him spit
that's why bottle and bond is did you
guys know this about bourbon bottle and
bond was because they were trying to
sell Bourbon and they just they were
cutting it and a lot they were the food
coloring was tobacco spit oh them really
which also tells you how little people
cared about the bourbon taste back then
they were they weren't in a Glencairn
glass or a snifter they were just I
don't care I'll drink the spit so let's
go on to this the proud boys oh sorry
this gag reflex this hot mouth it's fine
hot milk it's just fine now before we
move on to the fact here I do have a
question for you and please comment
below what is your gut instinct on the
22-year sentencing of Enrique uh tario
right this is the longest one that we've
seen from January 6th yep the second
longest one I believe was just earlier
this week and it was like 16 years
before there was an 18-year sentence for
I can't remember what the guys it was an
18-year sentence okay so it was 18.
members leader of a different group um
and I'm going to explain to you why they
are trying to make an example of The
Proud boys and I'm going to give you a
brief history uh lesson on the Proud
boys what they actually are you may not
like them you may think it's a silly
organization but to act as though this
is a terrorist organization or to act as
though this person deserves 22 years in
prison is to Simply Be ignorant of the
facts and it is terrifying that we have
our intelligence agencies weaponized to
this degree so if you missed it Tuesday
former leader of the proud boys they
have to remove white supremacists from
it because his name is Enrique tario and
you'll understand when you see the
pictures 22 years in prison
today Judgment Day for Enrique tario
former leader of the problem is for his
role in a seditious conspiracy that led
to the January 6 attack on the capitol
Terrio sent us to more than two decades
in prison 22 years the longest imposed
thus far in connection with January 6.
yeah now just to be clear they were
pushing for 30 something years 33 years
I believe is the original sentence and
to put this in context uh
this is the largest Justice Department
investigation in United States history
January 6th does that means bigger than
the Boston bombing bigger than Waco
bigger than Oklahoma City Epstein Hunter
Biden way bigger than Epstein because we
still don't have a single name yeah
absolutely so I don't even think they've
done it way bigger than that
come on although Epstein is you know
he's he's big on he's big on rape Island
well that's where he's huge and very big
in Sheboygan so January 6th is the
largest Justice Department investigation
that would also mean by the way the Las
Vegas shooting
bigger than a Boston bombing bigger than
Oklahoma City bigger than Waco yes
Epstein in 22 years for what
for what a bunch of dummies walking into
the Capitol and then leaving the only
person shot was shot by Capitol Police
and it was a woman
this is the biggest investigation
wow an American intelligence history as
we're talking about uh the justice
department officially so let's go
through some claims and some truths in
how this actually affects you okay the
claim that they are trying to make here
so that you go yeah yeah first off you
have to accept that January 6 was the
deadliest day in American history it was
9 11 2 9 11 harder
I don't accept that but maybe you do but
even if you accept that okay you would
have to accept their claim that this
Enrique tario was The Mastermind behind
911 the sequel it comes after a jury
convicted him of seditious conspiracy
the judge calling tario quote the
ultimate leader of the conspiracy
prosecutors say it was members of The
Proud boys who first broke through the
metal gates around the Capitol and that
tario was watching posting messages on
social media okay so here's the truth
and we'll make all these references
available this comes also from the
prosecution tario 22 years in prison was
nowhere near the capitol on January 6th
and before I get to it I know you're
gonna say oh he was the one who worked
he did not orchestrate it nope he did
not call for violence so January 5th
tario had been banned from DC after he
was arrested for vandalizing a black
lives matter uh Banner now the black
lives matter activists were not uh uh
banned or arrested for vandalizing
public property you've analyzed their
Banner now we're going to have to go to
the rule book according to NBC News
tario in encrypted this is this is them
admitting ittario in encrypted messages
revealed during the trial
acknowledged receiving a message meaning
tario acknowledged receiving a message
from someone who wanted to quote storm
the capital but did not directly endorse
the plan
this is also from NBC News prosecutors
seemed to concede that much of what
happened on January 6th happened
spontaneously so it happened
spontaneously he did receive a text
which by the way could have been from a
Fed saying hey we're going to storm the
capital he never even respond he never
even responded with an endorsement of
that plan and he was nowhere near
Washington DC when January 6 9 11 the
sequel happened 22 years in prison 22
years in prison so you're telling me
that a guy is going there to overthrow
the government the government is
actually trying to pump up the ability
to sentence by putting terrorism charges
on this I'm not kidding that's what they
did to try to plus up the sentencing to
be able to ask for that many years and
he is such a threat he is so bent on
overthrowing the government that you ban
him from Washington DC and he goes and
sits in a Baltimore Hotel you're telling
me that's the guy what would have
happened if you had been I don't know
Osama Bin Laden from coming to the
Capitol he's like oh I guess I guess I
can't fly planes like what's a good
thing I got the good price line and the
W I know you think that that is really
the guy that's the leader of this that
is the threat to America you simply ban
him from coming to the city and he
abides by yourself he didn't show up
come on terrorists just make any sense I
can't I can't do anything we can't take
the planes why because they told us we
can I don't know I don't know they took
our frequent flyer numbers away all of
us
here we come what the hell did this guy
have a public defender I mean I don't
know how often just does his
representation have to be to frame well
so here is the the one piece of evidence
that they try and point to again they
admitted he wasn't there they admitted
that he never responded endorsing the
plan afterwards they claim that he he
said he wanted a spectacle and
celebrated uh the incursion uh giving
the proud boys credit so he celebrated
the idea of a spectacle January 6th and
he gave the proud boys credit uh yeah
but so did these guys so that doesn't
that's not a reason to put someone in
prison different proud boys okay maybe
they're not boys it looks like Francis
and ganu in a clown wig and Fisherman's
[Laughter]
we have kids watching I shouldn't be
here's another claim hidden school kids
yes it's worse not if you're in the
Ridgefield no that's right
uh tario received a fair sentence that's
what they want you to believe
boy I used to not fully understand the
term gaslighting now when you live it
it's like all I smell is ethanol yeah
this this guy we're about a piece of
crap yes Brian krasins oh so when Gerald
gets fired up you know what's better
Brian krasenstein said 20 25 years seems
fair compared to the other sentencing
I'd be fine with anything over 15 years
let me let me just pull that back up for
me real quick real quick
compared to the other people's
sentencing so basically what you're
doing is using as your barometer for
what this guy deserves is that other
people were screwed so he needs to be
screwed worse but he liked that they
were screwed just like the uh
superintendent he's citing his own
opinion but where's this guy's voice
where's his voice where are his people
his representation they should be and
this is why Donald Trump has made
everything public because what happens
is you're surrounded by your lawyers and
they say okay look keep it quiet we'll
do this plea deal because they want to
minimize their risk and their losses
they say do this trust me then maybe we
can plea it down then once it happens
they're gone and they'll probably go on
to clients and other clients and say
that they got this guy A reduced
sentence as though it was a win yeah do
not go quietly into that good night just
to be clear you do not do that these
people do not play fairly when you are
dealing with our intelligence agencies
they are weaponized they are ladies
there are parasites out there um to the
teeth two bottle opens hopefully cold
outside here's another one author Tommy
ahonen says this is what Justice looks
like enjoy prison
look
this man's life is destroyed for an
event that had nothing to do with him
and he wasn't even there yeah
by the way you have people
you have people praising Rand Paul
getting the kicked out of him by
his neighbor
you have people praising all the time
when you see right Wingers who are being
assaulted you had people by the way
praising the man who was shot in the
head I was at Portland or was it Seattle
I can't remember because they kind of
shot him and that's it we got a Maga
here boom and you had plenty those
people aren't in jail this man didn't
praise the murder of anyone because
there were no murders aside from the one
lady killed by Capitol policemen we
don't really have any investigations on
that too busy investigating a guy who's
cosplaying you know as a paramilitary
group all right here's another truth is
of course the context matters the
sentencing is it's not proportional at
all so let's let's let's kind of compare
and contrast here let's look at him okay
January 6th again no there wasn't even
that much damage done to be clear yeah
uh even the Q Anon Shaman said you know
we have to be peaceful the guy who was
the guy who was held out is the example
of the most dangerous extremist in the
country he didn't hurt anybody he was
escorted so let's compare January 6th no
deaths
on his head though that's why he looked
me yeah
let's compare to Black lives matter
protesters by the way you have hundreds
of casualties meaning deaths and serious
injuries you have billions in Damages so
let me give you this this stat is kind
of shocking to understand 120 defendants
okay they pled guilty or they were they
were completely convicted of not charged
convicted
wiping out sorry I'm just being French
they were either pled guilty or they
were convicted what are you say in
English instead of pointy now period
period okay
my mom whenever she gets out she goes
that's it that's a point
period okay
120 defendants fled guilty or they were
convicted full stop of federal crimes
like rioting arson conspiracy the
average sentencing across 120 defendants
serious violent felonies 27 months 22
years for a man who wasn't there
who didn't throw a punch who didn't
throw a stone
22 years 27 months for people who pled
guilty or were convicted of arson
do you feel free
a lot of them by the way had no prison
time they didn't actually end up serving
any prison time or they had their cases
dismissed and of course not just black
lives matter uh remember antifa who by
the way they took credit for the violent
assault we encountered it ourselves
we've had our own producers assaulted by
the way through antifa so we've
experienced it and you see of course the
numbers across again hundreds of
casualties hundreds of serious injuries
and even some deaths
but you have your intelligence if
remember Christopher Ray said no no no
that's not a real thing
I appreciate that we we look at antifa
as more of an ideology or a movement
than an organization now let me add ah
let me add another little wrinkle here
not only were the people who were
convicted uh federal charges of arson of
rioting of violent uh assault
um causing serious bodily injury not
only did many of them not serve any
prison time Not only was the average
sentencing time 27 months versus 22
years in some cities like Denver uh
their municipality had to pay out black
lives matter protesters for using quote
excessive force to control the crowds so
in other words
these people aren't charged who create
these kinds of violent riots and then
when you try and control them you have
to pay them out because you needed to
use excessive force we used to just
refer to it as Force to control crowds
in Denver exactly like these
shut up
[Applause]
that's excessive right there
hold on that's so excessive the guy on
his phone doesn't even look dead he's
like yeah whatever yeah huh do you want
a hoagie or uh pizza
with his travel agent he's like yeah
they're gonna owe me a lot of money yeah
it's so now I alluded to Walgreens and
they just fired some tear gas the city's
gonna have to pay me out how do you
think what do you think about Cabo here
they have nice properties down there but
a lot of these plea deals though they're
just they're not an admission of guilt
it's it's the weight of the federal
government it's going to be on you to
wear you down to run the meter on you
and you tap and it's unending that's
right and they choose stops the targets
yeah that's what it is
or anybody like that ever brought in for
questioning right I mean I know that I'm
I'm beating a dead horse here but the
horse is still alive and very free in
this case yeah and has not been brought
in for questioning but these guys lives
well overturned and let me tie this all
together as to why so remember black
lives matter their leader Patrice colors
um of course was huge in the George
Floyd uh uh protests and venerated the
George Floyd protesters including the
violent ones and again this is direct
apples app called for the abolition of
the police yeah right called for the
abolition of the police so people in
January 6 questioning the results of an
election that by the way were completely
unprecedented with mail-in voting that
had never been seen before in violation
of state constitutions they're not
allowed to question their government
when you have these people actively
calling for the abolition of the police
when we have a record police officer
casualties
this person was absolutely not charged
with anything instead was given multiple
Awards so that's a stark contrast to 22
years in prison but don't worry it all
worked out Justice was served because
she was able to afford a multi-million
dollar homes but it's not an
organization it's more of an idea it is
it's more of an idea yeah she has an
indoor outdoor pool now but from an idea
yeah exactly but and man don't forget
the the politicians Kamala Harris people
like that who said that they shouldn't
get out of the streets when the Black
lives matter people were rioting and
actually setting up funds or
contributing to funds to get those
people out of jail that have been I
guess excessive forced I don't really
know yeah how to deal with this because
they're not they're not in any trouble
at all I think from any of that those
are people that burned down the
Minneapolis Police house uh police well
no that's not a that's not actually a
police house that's just that's a white
supremacy building yes
I mean of course you know the black
don't tell the black police officers
they weren't in on the gag
they're the black face of white
supremacy as we've heard and the reason
they're doing this right now you see
they we're just talking about on CNN
they were talking about Donald Trump and
Georgia and they were talking about his
indictment this is why they're trying to
make an example of this person again 22
years unprecedented was not there did
not commit violence did not endorse
violence is because they want to tie
these people they want you this is
this is okay the connection
it's very simple start off January 6th
deadliest day in American history
Insurrection you have to accept that
premise then proud boys were behind it
and deserve to be locked up for life
okay then you know who supported the
proud boys he basically is a de facto
proud boy Donald Trump we need to indict
him harder
well if the general who commanded Donald
Trump's Army
gets 22 years in federal prison for what
he did on January 6th what does the
commander-in-chief
of Donald Trump's Army get
if he is found guilty that is the
question that Donald Trump's criminal
defense lawyers are thinking about
tonight with the breaking news that the
leader of these so-called proud boys was
sentenced to 20 years
for his leadership of what prosecutors
called Donald Trump's Army okay a couple
of points here first off why so-called
proud boys it's like the is this uh
Steve Eiserman who was a player for
these so-called Detroit Red Wings but
they are that yeah and have been I mean
so called
it's not so cold that's their name what
do you mean the organization that swears
off pornography and uh dedication to
their wives yeah white supremacy
organization yeah and by the way what do
you think they're doing maybe some
leverage how much do you want to bet
comment below I'm calling it now they're
gonna find some former proud boys who
knew their best friend's girlfriends
sisters brother's girlfriend who knew
this guy who saw Donald Trump at the
proud boys 31 Flavors last night this is
what they're going to do hey you were a
proud boy did you did you have any
direct communication with uh Donald
Trump uh no I didn't but you liked him
yeah I did guilty done
that's what they want to do can I can I
just bring this back to something
because I think this all stems from one
particular event that we called out that
I think took almost a year because it
was delayed by a hurricane that was 7
000 miles away the January six hearings
do you remember this this phony hearing
yeah we did a full stream when we had a
couple of Republicans who thank God
they're out of government now because
these people were simply the worst
trying to lend legitimacy to something
like this it was this big propaganda
machine saying that January 6 was the
biggest and worst problem that we've
ever had in the government the biggest
attack on the government and look we
even have Republicans here that are
saying this they never brought in
anybody to counter any of the opinions
and so what they did is forced everybody
to think that this was like you said 911
too and so we have to treat these people
as terrorists now because we've had a
hearing on this we've had all the
evidence brought forth no you have had a
dog and pony show you have had somebody
come out with I'm not kidding the worst
propaganda that I have seen in my
lifetime and people are paying with it
with 20 22 years of their lives by the
way one of the other guys 17 year 18
years that we were talking about Ethan
Nordeen proud voice leader sentenced to
18 years right 18 and 22 years just
think about that you go to a protest and
you want a spectacle you know what a
spectacle could be make your voices
loudly heard maybe you don't Riot and
burn things down do we burn anything
down make your voice make your voices
patriotically and peacefully heard there
you go never play that yeah it could be
hundreds of thousands of people marching
over to Congress and saying hey we don't
agree with what's going on that's a
spectacle afterwards going hey great job
guys I appreciate what you did that is
not a 22-year sentence violation I know
plenty of people who were there in
January 6. everyone also acts as well
they're they're afraid to say it a lot
no I don't play no that being said I
said oh what happened well I went down I
listened to Donald Trump speak and you
know then we do like Martian uh we left
we went home yeah that was it there are
plenty again keep in mind there were
hundreds of thousands of people there
that day who were protesting what they
not what they saw protesting the
violation of state constitution yeah for
example in Pennsylvania there are
multiple states that you could argue
violated their own state constitution
but they were protesting for example
Mass mail and voting which they would
say is unconstitutional they were
protesting the specific violation of
state constitutions they were protesting
what they saw as an elect and lockdowns
for example all of this had culminated
in there were there were many reasons
that hundreds of thousands of people
were protesting and then hundreds of
people
went into the capital and again hundreds
of people
majority of whom were escorted were
invited in just to be clear so this is
not don't let them Gaslight you or
January 6th the worst event in our
history nope not even close as a matter
of fact I think any given day during the
months of the black lives matter protest
which led up to this were worse proud
boys most dangerous domestic terrorist
organization nope not a member but it's
not even close and I certainly will put
antifung black lives matter for going by
I don't know murders up there Donald
Trump encouraged violence absolutely not
he said the opposite nothing that you
just said is true and it is a crime for
this guy to get 22 years in prison even
if you don't like them we have to remove
ourselves
uh from these equations where we go I
don't like this guy therefore look
I don't I don't care
what you do
if you're not a rapist murderer
pickpocket you don't get 22 years in
prison
maybe I disagree with your lifestyle
choices maybe disagree with the way that
you present yourself maybe you disagree
with The Branding it doesn't matter we
need to we need to take a step back here
and say hold on a second even if I don't
like this person does that mean that I
shouldn't fight for basic fundamental
civil rights here in the United States
especially when the guy committed no
violence and encouraged no violence what
kind of America do you want to live in
and to be clear they want you to live in
one where you don't stand up for these
people hey we always talk about Justice
we always talk about Civic engagement we
talk about where's the Justice here hey
These people aren't allowed this brown
man is not allowed to speak truth to
power who by the way followed the law
when you banned him
for vandalizing a black lives matter
flag
think about that first is that the kind
of country you want to live in you do
not live in a free country if your
country has laws
it's whether those laws are applied
equally and this is a scary time and you
know what you can correct a lot of it
with information and you can correct a
lot of it with your vote this is a live
show Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern you also get Alex Jones on
Friday hey we have investigative
journalism units here you get the Hodge
twins in October you get Nick de Paul
every day Brian Callan show Alex Jones's
show we're about to go on for another
hour here Mr guns and gear uh go to
lottery.com mug Club because it's what
allows us
to at least try and stand in that pocket
for even people we don't like even
people who have never met proud boys
people someone needs to say it someone
needs to stand up against wrong even
though it doesn't affect me maybe it
doesn't affect you you could be next so
Rumble thank you very much you guys can
click that button join mug club we
appreciate it Rumble I don't know how
many times with the YouTube dump button
today 20 or so quite a few oh we're
about to play the game because pop
Crowder is here also uh Zoomer slang oh
my gosh YouTube piss off
oh
[Applause]
[Music]